it's a long process and it involves your
entire life it's not like one day just
like okay I knew I was gay like for sure
gay cuz I was finding stuff on the
internet and I was all about it I
actually think it was a day it was a
Disney movie
I remember my girlfriends and I used to
practice kissing on each other and all
the girls would be like okay well we're
just doing this because we're practicing
now for the boys and I'd be like this is
the best jackpot like I was super into
it for me it was very much just clear
that there was one main driver for my
sexual energy and that was women women's
bodies are great I just like there's a
literally no drive within me to like
explore them on a sexual level my
coming-out story is just kind of like
and then I met one girl and I was like
oh I just remember being 11 and 12 and
all of my girlfriends talking about boys
they liked and and I also liked boys but
also having crushes on girls I've never
fallen in love with men you know what
I've had boyfriends never like woke it
up until I got it's so good to see you
and I'm so happy here in my life when I
have girlfriends I'm like I'm like a
puppy all the way through high school I
would say things like well just just
something about the way a guy holds you
that women are hot and they're beautiful
and I love to touch them but I wouldn't
seriously date a woman I wouldn't marry
a woman things like that as I've gotten
older I feel like I have a deeper I'm
able to have a deeper connection with
women that's not so surface being gay is
about being in love it's not about sex
no if I agree with that I I could see
myself falling in love with a man much
more easily than I could see myself
having sex with a man when it comes to
like emotional love beyond sex like an
emotional just like huge upheaval of
everything but I know I've never felt
that intense of something with a girl
nor have I longed to have that with a
girl or met a girl that I thought I
could have that with for me being gay
and my personal identity are totally
different thanks sometimes I wear heels
sometimes I wear combat boots I like
jazz
love the internet you know what I mean
like that's my personal identity
that's absolutely nothing to do with
being gay I loved collecting Lisa Frank
stickers I mean like I loved it and I
you know to this day like I just for
some reason man like those little
freaking rainbows the awesome I think
from my uncle he saw this as like some
kind of like threat but that never
really liked interfered with the
conversation that I sort of I guess was
having internally conscious or not about
what my sexuality was I definitely
didn't want to be gay pardon me still
doesn't want to be gay makes life a
little bit harder I think the hardest
obstacle for me has been people telling
me that bisexuality isn't actually a
thing like you have to choose one or the
other or you're doing it for attention
it's not true you can like both if
you're struggling through sexuality I
guess the thing that I have to say is is
be comfortable and be okay just being
the only person who's comfortable with
your sexuality
once you're okay with that other
people's acceptance will come the good
news is it's getting better a lot of
people are going to be there for you and
there's tons of resources out there
whether you are so distraught by it
words problematic in your life and you
mean the trevor project a lot more
people are supportive than you think and
if you need help there's always people
on youtube telling their story and I'm
sure you will relate to somebody on
there just keep searching and you're not
alone